hey guys it's congratulations the
podcast in this episode is brought to
you by blue apron look blue apron is the
number one fresh ingredient and recipe
delivery service in the country that's
all 50 states okay
I think there's 50 states and if there
are this is the number one blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone it
achieves this by supporting more
sustainable food system because I was
like how does it achieve this it was
like I was like how does it do it oh
it's by supporting a more sustainable
food system setting the highest
standards for ingredients and building a
community of home chefs if you check out
this week's menu on the website you get
your first 3 meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron calm
slash Congrats this episode is also
brought to you by Square cash square
cash is the [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know if
I'm supposed to say that but I'm saying
it ok you want to pay somebody back you
use square cash so what you do you
peasant nah were you digging in your
pockets that's so 1990s download the app
Square cash and pay back friends family
to cans whoever your own money to you
can give it to them it's totally free
and fast so go and download the square
cash app now for iOS or Android what up
my babies how you doing Chris D'Elia and
this is episode I think 13 of what do
you call it congratulations
congratulations and the sound is of a
hotel room and it is because it is
because we are in Toronto and see now
I'm here's the thing I'm by myself doing
this and now let me just give you a
little behind-the-scenes thing here
alright I'm behind the scenes I'm asking
my producer stuff on text message while
I'm doing it while I'm recording you
this does it kind of [ __ ] that [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] I don't like okay I'm
asking them stuff what to do
how to do this I say I'm recording I
need to know how to do this and that had
to do this and that with the [ __ ]
microphone and all the [ __ ] and the ad
reads and he sends me a [ __ ] voice
note dude now I'm mad
now I'm mad cuz that's common sense you
understand it's common sense to not send
a voice note when somebody's recording
but he decided to send a voice note nom
bloodred mad and what we call BRM miss
blood red mad it's what it is
anyway umm so that's what he did this is
kind of [ __ ] people I'm working with
and Here I am in my hotel room in
Toronto and I had that I went to the
whole thing is I started to record and
it there was a hum in the room and I
turned off the air which I put the heat
on you know how I like my heat I put the
heat on I turn the heat off and then and
then it was still humming and so I
called down and I said hey could you
guys have somebody come up to turn off
the air because I still hear it and the
guy came up and was like you want me to
turn the hair the air off and I was like
yeah because you know I hit off on the
thing and that should be that should be
off by the way you hit the [ __ ] thing
off it's off
what I have to call somebody - it's off
if you hit it off um but it wasn't off
so I had to call him up and he came in
and had to open up like some door I
didn't even know my hotel my room had it
was like one of those doors you'd see in
Kingsman and he hit it a thing and it
went right off and he was like call me
if you need the air to be turned back on
again
nah hey man just I'll just hit the on
button what was the deal it doesn't go
off the V it off why is there an off
button
oh it doesn't go off when you get off
why is that's cool back a quick question
for you then why is there an off button
so there's gonna there's gonna be uh you
know some some [ __ ] sound stuff
going on but this is how it is dude this
is the [ __ ] rough in it episode this
is the roughening episode of am
congratulations the podcast we're in the
wild
in Tirana Tirana [ __ ] Ontario and
we're roughing it in a [ __ ] hotel
room you get or noises in what not um
see because I didn't bring my actual
microphone so I'm just talking into this
[ __ ] gadget the zoom umm but yeah so
uh dude the [ __ ] rude boys and Tings
in Toronto are unbelievable man there's
so many rude boys there's so many things
I'm just like you know I'm just like
beside myself uh and by the way people
are coming up to me and saying like hey
rude boy and hey I'm a ting or whatever
the [ __ ] you know and I don't know how
to react to that I just go like this uh
okay alright and then I think they feel
uncomfortable but it's like you're gonna
feel uncomfortable then because I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna be the one that
feels uncomfortable about it so if you
walk into a place say I'm at a wherever
I am a library I'm never there though
cuz the Internet but if I'm at a library
and then somebody says hey rude boy
you're not gonna make me the one who's
[ __ ] uncomfortable I look at you like
because everyone then looks at me for
the reaction right like I say like even
if they don't know who I am if somebody
walks into a cafe and I'm sitting there
reading the script and then [ __ ]
somebody walks in which happen the other
day and says hey rude boy you're not
going to make me [ __ ] uncomfortable
so cuz everyone then looks to the guy
right if you walk into a cafe and say
something crazy to somebody then
everyone looks to the guy the other guy
that's been talking to and it's up to
him to [ __ ] and smooth out the situation
guess what I do I turn it right the [ __ ]
back around on you I look at you like I
don't know you and I don't know what
you're talking about and then they just
think you're crazy and then you you get
uncomfortable but guess what you put it
on yourself alright
you put it on yourself you got to deal
with life's issues you put energy out
you get the same energy back in that's
the [ __ ] Karma [ __ ] I don't believe
in karma
cuz I am karma yes dan um I was talking
to uh my friend who is in Toronto
shooting uh uh he shoots that show
designated survivor and he's a buddy of
mine and he he was talking about Karma
that it that it he says he lives his
life a certain way because he doesn't
want the energy he put out if it's
negative to come back on him and I know
that's like a common thought I mean I
hear so many things about karma you
can't go one well you can't go [ __ ]
three steps without somebody mentioned
something about karma but uh and I
believe in energy sure you know like it
all comes around right like if I if I
post something down the street and you
know it's gonna [ __ ] keep rolling and
rolling even if I'm not there and then
somebody's maybe it'll hit somebody
right okay you go I [ __ ] made
something happen because I used energy
and if I say to somebody [ __ ] you you
piece of [ __ ] they get upset and they
walk around town and then somebody else
like their dry-cleaning isn't ready and
then they're like you know what you
piece of [ __ ] you said was gonna be
ready by 6:00 p.m. I'm here at six
[ __ ] thirty where's my dry cleaning
and they're just really transferring my
energy on to that person who doesn't
necessarily deserve it but maybe they do
you know what I mean maybe they do need
it because they're [ __ ] dry cleaning
isn't ready but here's what I'm saying
is just because you are a [ __ ] say if
you're an [ __ ] to somebody that
doesn't mean it's gonna come back around
and bite you in the ass so if that's
what you mean by karma dude bad things
bad things happen to good people and
good things happen to bad people dude
and that's how it is so if you [ __ ]
live your life and you're like oh I do
this because I don't want bad things
happen first of all your that's not what
a good person does a good person doesn't
do good [ __ ] because they want good [ __ ]
to happen to them he a bad person that's
evil you selfish all right if you want
[ __ ] if you don't give a [ __ ] you say
you know what whatever happens happens
but I'm just gonna be a good person
because that's what I that's who I am
then you're good person
right but if you believe in Carmen you
like I'd better be a good person because
I don't want bad things happen to me a
piece of [ __ ] so don't talk to me about
Karma
talk to me about how a bad person um but
we went out I never go out i straight-up
never go out I go out and do my shows
and then I go home and and my good my
life is going out you know because I go
out and I do stand-up and then I go to
the diner and I go home but I didn't
have [ __ ] to do I'm shooting this movie
here in Toronto with some Tings and rude
boys and um yeah I'm shooting this movie
with some things and rude boys oh and um
I don't know you know they were like
well you know the guys were like hey
what you gon do and I was like I don't
know what I'm going to but it'll come
out and I said all right maybe I'll
[ __ ] this rude boy we'll go out you
know it's not something I normally do
but maybe I'll go you know maybe it's
[ __ ] something i'm gwon do right so
um I went I went out and I hung out and
it was cool man mixed company hung out
with some friends another buddy Jackson
McQueen who's a hilarious comedian he
was out there - lamonica Garrett who is
[Music]
on that show designated survivor but he
might I did that movie EXO I did the
movie xoxo with him and uh and then a
guy named Richie uh Watkins who was
[ __ ] awesome and a great actor and we
all hung out and it was cool man they
had Lamonica is already in had been in
Toronto for a while so he like knew the
ropes and I was like the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know I mean I was like huh so this
is like your huh you know like the guy
in the movie it was like yeah man yeah
he was cool he's super tall and just
jacked and I'm just and I was like the
[ __ ] sidekick that was like not cool
so this is what's Ronald like huh huh
all right pretty cool huh I'll have a
milkshake I don't drink
they're all [ __ ] drinking like not
heavy but like just having some drinks
and I was like that yeah I'll stick with
a soda water ha ha ha ha
a little didn't you mind if I get
another one but anyway we went out we
were rude boys you know and and that's
it so I shot one day in the movie so far
I've been here since Tuesday and it's
cool they made me shave and they made me
and I've just I thought it was gonna be
cool cuz I was going to shave and I was
gonna like nobody's gonna be able to
like to recognize me like but that
didn't happen they still they still do
which is kind of cool you know made me
feel good is I got people still Know Who
I am man it's not it's not like they
know my face is like they know behind my
eyes you know um
so uh yeah I I did we did that and then
um I I get to work with Cuba Gooding jr.
which is [ __ ] awesome
I met him on set and he is the [ __ ] he's
like one of those guys it's crazy when
when you've watched an actor so long
that that and then you meet them and
then they're talking to you telling you
a story and you and they're not acting
but you're like oh [ __ ] like you have
the same mannerisms as all the [ __ ]
guys you've played like I know that
sounds really dumb but it's like you
you're like oh you're Cuba Gooding jr.
being so Cuba Gooding jr. right now you
know and it's just [ __ ] cool and I got
to act with him and get into like a
little art get into an argument [ __ ]
did a scene with him and but there's
much much more I got a lot of [ __ ]
work coming up and I'm being a Toronto
I'm going to be in Toronto for [ __ ]
three weeks and then I come back to
shoot the end of the movie so uh yeah
that's it numb so that so that's what
I'm doing so I'm trying to [ __ ] I
went up last night um to uh to Yuk Yuk's
the comedy club and I and I popped in I
did a set there at 8:00 8:00 p.m. and
and it's a [ __ ] great club man I did
Yuk Yuk's
um and the
crowd oohs crowd oohs is Canadian they
were so super Canadian like I said [ __ ]
a few times and I felt like when I say
[ __ ] when I said [ __ ] on stage every
time a lot of them in their head were
going oh yeah okay oh he's gonna swear
huh like and um I don't maybe was in my
head but I don't think it was because it
was the eight o'clock show and before me
like some super Canadian comics went on
and then I went on and I was like
[ __ ] dick [ __ ] grabbing [ __ ] ass
and they were okay yeah oh you're gonna
say dick [ __ ] grab and I say oh okay
okay he's gonna say dick [ __ ] grabbing
us no no it's all good I just okay let
me just settle in here honking ha ha ha
ha ha so I did my set I don't know if it
was good some cast members come to see
me so I wanted to do well you know some
of the people who are [ __ ] way more
famous than me came to do came to see me
so I wanted to do well ah that's how
insecure I am even though I don't give a
[ __ ] you know I give I give off that
vibe I give a [ __ ] you give a [ __ ] you
know you don't really give a [ __ ] you
give a [ __ ] you gotta give a [ __ ] a
little bit right I was talking to the
group text I got this group text going
on it's [ __ ] the killer and uh if you
don't have a good one or two group text
by the way you're nothing in this world
your 2017
your two thousand and nothing what is
that um Fergie song your 2009 well I
don't know what the [ __ ] she says that's
what you are [ __ ] are okay if you got
one or two group text messages going on
it's pretty good you got three or four
your fire if you go five or six
you're practically Dikembe Mutombo dude
you're murder in it you're murdering and
nobody can grab that ball from you man
you got it high up in the sky um get a
more comfortable situation here um so
yeah so so I got like five or six I'm
[ __ ] disc em babe matumbo on [ __ ]
Manute Bulls
[Music]
shoulders bro I got a lot of [ __ ]
group text going on and we got one
killer one going on and my buddy was
telling me um and somebody my buddy was
telling me uh yeah
if so any anybody who's like yeah I'm
the [ __ ] and [ __ ] you haters I'm the I'm
the baddest [ __ ] or whatever you know
that that's the most si insecure person
and I you know I believe that so I'm
telling ya I don't give a [ __ ]
secretly I can't [ __ ] you know I mean
you gotta give a [ __ ] a little bit
that's why you got oh oh you don't give
a [ __ ] dude why you wearing pants yo you
don't give a [ __ ]
real quick why you got pants on hey if
you don't give a [ __ ] take your dick out
rolling around in Starbucks huh if you
don't give a [ __ ] take your dick out
leave your belt loop you know buckled
unzip your pants take your dick and
balls hook them out hook your balls out
okay so they're just so they're so
they're so they're flopped over so
they're sticking out just your dick
balls out like in the in the like in the
website what the [ __ ] is it there's some
porn amateur alert that's what it is but
there's a porn site amateur lore and the
guy only takes his dick and balls out
and it's hilarious he never takes his
pants off he just takes his dick and
balls out and then has sex with a girl
do that if you don't give a [ __ ] do the
amateur Lawrence Starbucks oh [ __ ] oh my
god if you don't give a [ __ ] do the
amateur lure the cusco take your dick
and balls out you know these rappers I
don't give a [ __ ] oh really Ludacris go
to Home Depot do that mature Lord oh man
a lot of rappers don't give a [ __ ] but
secretly give a [ __ ] you know how you
know you know rappers give a [ __ ]
they're buying lots of jewelry they're
buying lots of [ __ ] jewelry how about
how rappers the most they're like so
many of them are homophobic but so many
of them dressed like women um or not
even that gay man
they have like pink furs on and [ __ ] and
they'll be like I ain't into that gay
[ __ ] my favorite line in hip-hop that
makes me laugh the hardest probably ever
was when jay-z was doing that song it's
called a blue Airways called the
something excuse me [ __ ] part two and
he's wrapping and wrapping and wrapping
and for no reason he says I and until I
can dudes no way and and then he goes
back to wrapping and you're like wait
hold on what it was like in the middle
of the rap song like somebody that like
the producer was just like you gay
like in Wally's wrapping he was like
yeah got [ __ ] buying in the like of
rap ain't in like in dudes no way and
then went to rapping again I got my by
the way I got more money now that was so
weird but I left so hard when it did
that when that song happened I ended up
liking dudes no way hey nobody said [ __ ]
nobody said you liked dudes who the [ __ ]
ever called jay-z gay I nail it I could
do is no way so um and I jay-z doesn't
really [ __ ] stunt that much you know
but a lot of rappers stunt and it's like
well don't if you don't give a [ __ ]
don't stunt you know it doesn't give a
[ __ ] I heard about this guy
spooky black he's an R&B singer he's
like a 19 year old white kid that looks
like you just [ __ ] find him somewhere
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] do it I
watched a video of him and he's singing
like he it's like he's about to fall
asleep and he and his and he has a shirt
on that had it that has a vasa it says
that has the Vaseline logo on it he has
a shirt on and it says the word it has
the Vaseline logo on it it was like it
was like you got maybe I don't know what
his [ __ ] financial situation is but
it was like he got it from the Salvation
Army and he just I mean I don't I just
gotta have money to he's got millions of
hits but he was like yo let's make this
mumbles like make this music video he
was I should you change and then spooky
black was like nah [ __ ] that I wear what
I'm wearing and he's like but you and
your PJs don't care and then start
saying the guy sounds amazing dude it's
unbelievable it's so
anyhow this dude he's like nineteen year
old white kid that you just find
somewhere and he sounds like Beyonce as
a man it's a maze great um so uh was I
got up on a tangent I mean that's really
what I what I've been doing but as the
Sun Goes Down man in Toronto I'm doing
this Sunday night
this is what I'm recording it little
[ __ ] a little little behind the
scenes [ __ ] I don't like I only like to
know what I'm recording so I like it I
want you to think I'm with you right now
you know what I mean I want you to think
I'm with you in your car driving to work
I'm with you in your drawer in your
cubicle at work I'm with you in your
headphones while you're working out um
by the way there's cheers and [ __ ] going
on outside of my hotel room I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on it's like all
of a sudden there's a race or something
so I'm sure you can hear that in the
background but whatever dude you get it
how you get it man this is how you
[ __ ] get it um but yeah a lot a lot
of oh by the way man I was out last
night I went out twice dude twice so I'm
like the king of Toronto at this point
but um this is something I think it's
hilarious people in Toronto dress
immaculate dude it's like their clothes
are still hot from the [ __ ] dry
cleaners there they look so dope
everyone dresses so well
it's hilarious there was this one dude
last night he had on a [ __ ] beige
dopey [ __ ] uh um
sweater like a crewneck sweater and dope
is [ __ ] beige pants like he was like
this is how dope it was though I bet he
didn't even buy the outfit together he
was like I could buy it together but I'd
rather find two pages that were exactly
alike and wear
because then I earned this outfit so I
like to imagine that that's how it was
but then also he had on the same color
beige shoes dude and they were like
sneakers they were dope
he looked awesome and I was like man I
got to step my game up I only bought one
bag I was in like a [ __ ] light blue
button-down flannel and grey pants and
like these [ __ ] and the Jordans uh
the what do you call them Jordans the
Lance Mountain Jordans that I love but
then I had this black jacket on it
didn't go with it man like I'm trying to
keep it light and friendly and then I
had the black jacket on I'm like some
dad that kind of just figured out that
you could wear stuff to get [ __ ] you
know and I only brought one bag and this
guy's stuntin on me with a [ __ ] I got
beige man stuntin on me I mean he was so
ill he had two earrings in I don't even
remember if he had a hat on or not
that's how dope he was but this guy was
just [ __ ] and everybody though people
are wearing those circular [ __ ]
sunglasses you know what I'm talking
about like like like like like Harry
Potter on vacation or some [ __ ] I mean
he was dead I hate those sunglasses but
you know those are in his [ __ ] dude if
those were more in you could only buy
them tomorrow you know what I mean like
they're so in there's so now and all
these [ __ ] in Toronto have
those circular as Big Sean sunglasses
what what the [ __ ] did you get those
tomorrow I mean they're murdering it
dude I see guys with tight jeans and
like a long cold come on man
this is Toronto bro Toronto doesn't [ __ ]
around when drill by the way they like
Drake I don't know if you know that but
they play Drake six times in a row and
guess what
got no problem with that oh you hear
them go oh that was like to my podcast I
don't know if you can hear that or not
I got no problem you wanna listen to
Drake three [ __ ] times women Toronto
let's do this [ __ ] ting I'm gonna move
this though because that's bugging me
bugging the [ __ ] out of me oh man it was
cool how I moved how you could tell my
[ __ ] belt is undone because it's
[ __ ] it clinky clinky why not while I
was moving umm [ __ ] loving some
Toronto I'm just sitting in my hotel
room watching the [ __ ] sunset dude
that's some boss [ __ ]
I guess that's some boss [ __ ] right it's
not really some boss [ __ ] if you saw me
it sounds like some boss [ __ ] I like to
think of different scenarios and this is
I thought about this scenario the other
day I thought about this scenario the
other day the most boss [ __ ] you could
do this is the most boss [ __ ] you can do
I think is to invite a girl over if
you're a guy okay and say yeah you know
come hang out and then the girl shows up
and there's one orange on the table
while you're hanging and you grab it
while you're talking and you peel it
while you're talking and you eat the
whole thing while you while you guys are
talking and and you don't and you don't
offer her any like if you do that and
she doesn't sleep with you you're a
[ __ ] you you got like no nose or
something like that's the sexiest thing
you can do is to be like I want this to
not even reference it and to just be
like I'm a boss [ __ ] this is my
orange you you if you wanted some orange
you can either pipe up or maybe you got
some in your purse you should have
brought your own I mean nothing's more
of a boss move than than doing that I'm
gonna do that one
day one orange there can't there cannot
be more than one orange in the in the um
uh on the ball or whatever it has to be
one orange cuz then she could be like oh
I could eat that other one if I wanted
to she has to know she's not getting any
dude I don't know why I think that kind
of [ __ ] is the funniest [ __ ] ever but
like I think that like if I said that
kind of a thing on stage nobody would
get it you know um
but whatever that's how it is man that's
for you [ __ ] Tings Andrew Boystown to
to realize that's where you [ __ ] Tings
Andrew boys to [ __ ] call it's not up
to me it's up to you guys if you laugh
you laugh you don't you don't I want to
talk to you guys about blue apron blue
apron is we talked about this it's the
number one fresh ingredient recipe
delivery service in the country you got
to do this blue apron thing man it's got
blue apron has established partnerships
with overall 150 local farms fisheries
and ranchers across the United States
and because of that you know beef
chicken and pork pork pork no not poor
pork they come from responsibly raised
animals and that's important man you
don't want to be eating these chickens
that they raise and lock in the cages
and just raise to eat like that the
produce is sourced from farms that
practiced regenerative farming alright
and blue apron can be delivered to 99%
of the Connaught so you're like oh I
can't I don't know if I cameras in my
area oh you live in 99% of country you
can get it all right it it's it's great
it builds strong family bonds you can
cook together with each other and hey
guess what research you know research
like the official thing that we never do
shows up blue apron families cook nearly
three times more often and that's good
because it's healthier and it's better
and you got some upcoming meals that if
you sign up now sweet-and-sour salmon
with bok choy carrot and ginger fried
rice want it soon as I said it wanted it
parmesan crusted chicken with creamy
fettuccine and roasted broccoli want it
if I don't eat it tonight
you know I'll explode um so yeah so
that's blue a blue apron if you check
out this week's menu on the website you
get your first three meals free with
free shipping by going to blue apron com
/ Congrats blue apron com / Congrats
you'll love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with blue apron so don't wait blue apron
com / Congrats square cash this app you
downloaded it yet because I know that
when I the podcast started I mentioned
this Square cash app and if you didn't
download it yet you piece of [ __ ] ok you
got to do this you got download that app
and you got to start to share money with
friends and family and polish gangsters
you got it you got to do this you
download the square cash app it links to
your debit or your credit card it's
super easy select an amount to send and
then type in a friend's phone number or
email address to complete a payment but
could it get easier
nah could it get easier nah then they'll
get a notification did they just receive
money that's it there's no gimmicks dude
so if you're trying to get some yo if
you're looking for some [ __ ] gimmicks
on the square cash app in that gonna get
dude you like gimmicks don't download
this square cash app you don't like
gimmicks get it you should have it
already get it yesterday
download square cash app for iOS and
Android now it's better than the other
guys it really is I use it and all the
other ones they don't offer instant
deposits square cash does nobody's
holding this money you send it the get
net you feel me by the way this is the
road if I this is the road I mean I know
I'm not on the road doing stand-up I did
do stand-up last night I mean so many
caveats to what I just said there were
40 caveats in one sentence but um this
is what we do on the road comics we sit
and we watch we sit in our hotel room
and we kick it and we watch you know we
watch TV you know we watch you know we
watch ice when I'm on the road I don't
even realize what I'm watching
I swear to God the French channels been
on for [ __ ] three hours in the other
room I know all the French actors that
are on that I've seen [ __ ] already
looped dude I know I know [ __ ] is like I
know it's like kind of dumb to say like
say this but the French are so French
they're the most of their country that
of anybody's country you know I'm trying
to say you know what I'm trying to say I
didn't say alright but you know what the
[ __ ] I'm trying to say like like Irish
people are super Irish but they are not
more Irish than French are French
Africans can be super African they're
not more African than French's are
French's dude French people you know I
turn on a [ __ ] the TV of the other day
you know it was on you know it was on on
the French Channel a [ __ ] movie called
mustache and I [ __ ] you not guys were
wearing like crew net cable knit
sweaters with [ __ ] collared button
downs under it
ah hey could you be more French oh dude
you could Olivia more friendship you
were a Baghdad all right you're the most
French guy ever in a movie called
mustache dude if somebody was like my
agents come in and were like hey man
they want you to be in a movie called
mustache my next response would be oh
[ __ ] well that's cool I guess I've never
been to France cuz that's where they're
definitely shooting better blue
blablabla blablabla bad there that's
what every line was sufentanil blah bluh
bluh bluh bluh blah bleh Cheetos Oh
Britta Pablo bleh bleh bleh let it do
blah blah blah blah Oh poo poo poo poo
poo moustache I don't call it moustache
oh my I don't know what it was about it
was in French but imagine when would I
have to be what would have to be on for
a movie called moustache it's not about
a moustache
you know why that
would be the most boring movie of all
time so what's it about and why is it
called moustache
I got to figure that out dude that's my
new detective [ __ ] I'm pretty [ __ ]
happy right now I got to tell you I'm
pretty [ __ ] happy right now man
and I feel like I should tell you this
because a lot of times people think
people don't understand that I'm joking
on this podcast and they think that like
oh he [ __ ] hates everything shut the
[ __ ] up
I'm having a good time joking around and
I'm razzing [ __ ] all right but
so I'm telling you right now I'm happy
dude I'm out here in Toronto I'm
shooting a movie I'm doing something a
little different it's a drama I'm
playing a part that I never would have
thought I would have played in the in
the next few years and I'm happy about
it it's a [ __ ] interesting part in
the movie that I'm very happy to do it's
got a great cast it's for Sony and I'm
[ __ ] happy about it and and I just
shot my third special and I wanted to do
something different right after I shot
my third special and this is it man I'm
lucky and I'm happy about it and I'm
thanking the [ __ ] universe or whoever
Nicolas Cage to [ __ ] in you know that
I'm that I'm that I'm able to do this
[ __ ] and and that's that because I don't
say I'm [ __ ] happy that much so I'm
saying it and I'm in this room in
Toronto while the Sun Goes Down and I
and you know what I just realized that
that [ __ ] screams were from now
actually they're actually they're
watching the goddamn hockey game next
door in the in the next at home and now
I'm back to angry that's what I'm so you
know it lasted for a little bit but
that's it wasn't a parade which would
have made me angry enough cuz don't have
parades hey you know I don't have
parades you actually I'm not you know I
don't have parades cuz just where you
can just walk around with shirts on and
[ __ ] with [ __ ] streamers you're gonna
sit around it you're gonna sit in a car
while it goes five miles an hour nah nah
you're gonna sit in a car and go as fast
as you go when you walk hey just walk
and don't do it with 70 other people
we're in the same shirt parades are for
the [ __ ] birds dude but they're not
it's not a parade it is a [ __ ] bunch
of guys as a bunch of
aliens in the next room watching the
[ __ ] Leafs play or I don't even know
the names I don't know the names dude
the fire you're watching the Chicago
Fire play
that's an NBC show I don't even know if
that's a [ __ ] team you watching the
[ __ ] hometown hongki's play my buddy
told me that in Canada if the final four
was on in basketball and also a regular
exhibition [ __ ] two Canucks game was
on in hockey that nobody would be
watching the final four and that's
awesome that's awesome that's so
Canadian and you be Canada you but guess
what Canada and Canadians you're not
more Canadians than the French are
French okay mustache you understand it
is not a mustache you know there was
mustache ah hey dude it was a movie
about a [ __ ] baguette with an easel
ah [ __ ] painting his Frenchie [ __ ] dude
they got a they got a good gym in the
hotel I'm at I'm sure I try so hard not
to not to say the hotels that I'm at and
[ __ ] like that cuz I don't more people
showing up and stabbing me but um yeah
they got a good gym and it's super hard
to work out for some reason I think it's
because I'm tired or jet-lagged or some
[ __ ] but it's also they have the heat on
in the gym because it's that that's the
one thing about Toronto I'm at the time
in Toronto where they don't realize that
it's getting warmer yet and the heat is
still on and all these establishments so
it's like it's like 65 degrees which
isn't that bad or [ __ ] 12 degrees
Celsius whatever the [ __ ] I don't know
what it means what the Celsius is but
you walk in and it's too hot is [ __ ] and
they're still the heat still on because
there's like oh it's still the winter
though yeah um so uh so it's so hot at
the gym but I guess it's good for
sweating it out but I [ __ ] had to wax
my chest which is gross dude I hated
that I had to do that I had to do it for
the part they want me [ __ ] clean dude
and they let me cleaning [ __ ]
and so I wax it and it's wet all over
and I [ __ ] got so read my chest was
this red that they had to [ __ ] put
makeup on it
Oh God Who am I Who am I you know
sometimes I think about my grandfather
and like about what the [ __ ] you would
say about what I was doing you waxing
his chest
hey is waxing it's his chest he was from
Queens New York my dad said he couldn't
say the word he couldn't say the letter
H he would say H you hear those guys
screaming how good could this goddamn
hockey game be every four seconds oh
chill dude it better be the first
[ __ ] third or fourth quarter whatever
it's a 1-bit third right where they come
first period does what they say because
they're going to tire themselves out
there by the end um so uh so uh yeah he
wouldn't say he couldn't say hej H and
my dad and his brothers would be like no
no just say 8se H okay say eh
and he go eh and say sorry eh eh
and they say like I put it together and
he go H I don't know if I believe that
[ __ ] but my dad told it to me so it must
be true and you know dads don't lie
right um but yeah anyway I'm happy but I
don't fully clothed by the way in my
hotel room if you're fully clothed in
your hotel room that's kind of weird you
know like just [ __ ] take your shoes
off at least I got my shoes on my pants
on I got a hoodie on like I'm like mm
you got to be [ __ ] naked as [ __ ] in
your hotel immediately that's the real
boss [ __ ] you know you think a high
level producers don't do that [ __ ] and
now they do that [ __ ] as soon as they
get into their [ __ ] hotel room they
do the amateur lure [ __ ] is what they do
they do that
oh that's what they do do it oh that's
what they do
let me check some
[Music]
some of these hashtags dude every every
[ __ ] Sunday Monday people write
gaming the systems I'm gonna start to
use that as the No congratulations pot
is the hashtag and I'm checking it here
we go
my buddy Dylan actually I don't know if
I've met him or not but he said @dy ll Y
P congratulations pot is the legit the
funniest ish I've ever listened to he
has me wheezing salute Christa Lea thank
you my man it's a shout out for you this
is a good one
this is the at the top the the @reply is
at never not had sex and the thing is
twink mask change it hey you got to
change that because two completely
different things that also both make a
zero sense you can't never not have sex
you'll die
you can't just always be [ __ ] you know
why because sometimes in life you're a
baby Twain mask what is it
by nonetheless the question is my friend
fingered his girlfriend in the back of
my car without my consent knowledge
while I was driving thoughts my thoughts
are be more be more observant twink mask
by the way how'd you find out it depends
if you found out while they were doing
it then they [ __ ] up you gotta be more
quiet if you're going to do some [ __ ]
like that okay but if you found out
later because they told you joke's on
you dude never not had sex well you
obviously sometimes don't have sex
because you were driving at that moment
so I don't like how not real your
Twitter handle it handle is so yeah a
lot of people responded last week to the
[ __ ] quotes things that I was saying
don't have the stupid [ __ ] his [ __ ]
quotes on Instagram very cool this dude
said Zach oil oil Zachary said I just
started watching a Netflix documentary
and realized it was the violin goat silk
one and
yeah bro that [ __ ] [ __ ] good
man that guy was some board asked
[ __ ] see ya
now here's the thing and this guy Rudy
Vasquez a true dcv 1994 not bad not bad
you got your name in there 1994 was
probably when you were born or something
people come to Disneyland and 80 degree
weather dressed dapper quote dapper
loved the park as me it made me gay okay
well I guess it's good um but dapper and
then he sent me a screenshot of dapper
day at Disneyland here's the deal man
if you're going to Disneyland already an
[ __ ] alright now I don't mean if you
got kids and you take them to Disneyland
you're not an [ __ ] you're a very
sweet human being but if you're one of
those people that's in their 30s and
you're going to Disneyland dressed
however Yan [ __ ] sweat char okay
because don't go to Disneyland if you're
into 30s because you know what it's not
fun and it's not cute fun and it's not
ironic fun it's what we call zero fun
you're doing too many things
stop stimulating your brain you're
boring you need stimuli um so dapper day
is I guess they're all dressed up as
like old timey [ __ ] I guess or
I guess they dressed up I don't know
they all they look like they have like
like nice outfits on or something I
don't really get it no no these people
dressed like the [ __ ] chipmunks
oh that's infuriating let me see what
this is oh I guess it's dressing as
Disney characters
let me look at this up on his Instagram
let me try not say that in the drug game
let me look at this up on Instagram let
me look at this happens on Instagram so
drunk dapper day here we go dapper day
oh
220,000 posts all right up and then
there's dapper day 2016 which means a
happens every year change it yeah I
guess you're going as Disney characters
okay yeah that's what it is yeah I just
don't get it you know if you got a kid
go do
it but don't are you 40 and you have fun
dressing up look I'm not telling you you
can't do it obviously you can do it
skree conch sri conch but you know if
you do it you're not gonna be at a
dinner table with me and look and that's
fine i'm not saying i'm the [ __ ] and you
gotta have dinner with me but we're just
not gonna see hide hide
um yeah these people dressed up as
everybody man Wow who has these outfits
you know do you rent them like this guy
just has a blue a light blue baby blue
blazer with a white bow tie and a and a
and a [ __ ] hat that looks like a
racist would wear and in a pastel like
violet button-down in white pants like
who has any of those out but those items
and then all of them like that's like
having one of those is like it's like
all of them is like you're all a Voltron
together like you need seven people to
have those outfits and that makes
Voltron this guy's all Voltron together
you catch me cuz I'm sayin I don't know
but props if you're [ __ ] bringing your
kids in you're dressing up and that's
cute as [ __ ] that's what I think if you
dress really nice and you want to do
with your kid you bring them and it
makes them happy that's cute as [ __ ]
dude and then try to make sure that that
kid doesn't change and grow and grow up
to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] because most
people do you know sometimes I look at
kids and I think how cute they are and
then I think I but they're such they're
gonna grow up and just be a [ __ ]
they're gonna they're gonna do
[ __ ] things we all do we all do
[ __ ] things yeah - sad thought
but I'm happy what else here we got here
well that's a stupid one Devon Wilson at
Devon Wilson one would you rather not be
able to make any new memories or see
everyone under five five as muffins that
guys obviously on some [ __ ] acid um
okay I don't want latest I want top here
we go and want the [ __ ] top ones um
oh wow this is funny somebody Nate at
that fresh fresh change it of course
change it that fresh fresh is your
handle bye he writes check out this lady
eating a melon on the floor in LAX and I
[ __ ] he has a picture of a lady
putting a [ __ ] watermelon on the
floor and she's scooping it out eating
it like a [ __ ] lunatic
dude that's like a dream I would have
yeah this lady was at the airport eating
half of a watermelon and she was my mom
but also kind of not my mom um so well I
think that about I think that about
wraps up by the way oh by the way dude
somebody got stung I meant to talk about
this up by a scorpion on United about a
[ __ ] few days ago there was a
scorpion on the plane how how does it
scorpion get on the plane how does this
scorpion get on the plane dude that's
like the [ __ ] the Sam Jackson movie I
gotta get these goddamn scorpions off
this [ __ ] plane United did
snakes on the plane was was that a
documentary about a United flight
dude you United just [ __ ] blows donkey
dicks man congratulations United you
blow donkey dicks you line up and you
blow donkey dicks I mean
dude they beat the [ __ ] out of somebody
and then a [ __ ] scorpion was on their
plane are you trying to fail turn round
I want somebody that you know what I
want I'm gonna ask people to do I'm
gonna [ __ ] ask people to ask United
employees to turn round legit record it
say hey turn round go up to the front
desk
hey yeah as a flight on time and when
they say oh no it's delayed 17 hours say
okay turn round and when they say what
say you know you know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking you know congratulations or some
[ __ ] I mean just come on turn round dude
I got to make shirts that say turn round
congratulations alright well that's it
man congratulations that was the 13th I
believe the 13th episode I have no idea
it could be the 12th or 14th I have no
[ __ ] idea
um but yeah so that's how we do it
thank you for listening and you could
check out by the way you could check out
the this week's menu on on on blue apron
I go to blue apron dot-com / congrats
and go check that out and the first 3
meals are free with free shipping too so
not like you know kind of free
completely free by going to blue apron
com / Congrats so you can do that and
also don't forget to download that
square cash app unless unless you
sincerely are a bad person because oh
you consider yourself noble person
you're noble person then get the square
cash app and then and and and and and
very quickly okay because if you don't
do it you piece of [ __ ]
Square cash app now thank you so much my
babies you guys are the best for
listening and listen to me man you got
to rate and review this please alright
cuz I [ __ ] you not if the numbers go
down I'll stop doing it
alright so share it with your friends
and you know share the links
rate it and review it please and
download it review it on iTunes catch it
on stitcher or all out of the ship so
that'd be a big help thanks very much
and shoot me questions and suggestions
at hashtag congratulations pod and I was
just kidding about the suggestions
because I [ __ ] absolutely will hate
that okay guys take care
eat piece of [ __ ]
[Music]